[Applaudissements]
et maintenant je vous invite à prendre
une grande inspiration et ensuite à
chasser l'air très très loin de vautours
et pendant que cela se passe
je vous propose de vous installer
confortablement et peut-être que vous
pouvez vous installer encore plus
confortable ou peut-être pas je ne sais
pas
[Applaudissements]
eric est en train de pneus teese est
notre passion j'attends son feu vert
pour commencer à l'opérer je suis
norvégien spécialisé dans la chirurgie
des tumeurs du cerveau et eric est
anesthésiste réanimateur en
neurochirurgie ensemble nous opérons des
tumeurs du cerveau sous hypnose
avant quand j'entendais parler d'hypnose
j'imaginais une forme d ôter risme ou
l'hypnose de spectacle ou une médecine
parallèle
et puis j'ai appris que l'hypnose
c'était une technique reconnue enseigner
est utilisé dans de nombreux domaines en
médecine aujourd'hui nous allons vous
expliquer comment l'hypnose peut aider
la chirurgie les veillées des tumeurs du
cerveau
oui vous comprenez bien nos passions
sont éveillés canton les opera crâne
ouvert alors l'intérêt de réveiller le
patient une fois le crâne ouvert c'est
pouvoir faire ce qu'on appelle une
cartographie de son cerveau car la
caractéristique remarquable du cerveau
c'est qu'il est plastique et c'est grâce
à cette plasticité qu'on peut tolérer
pendant parfois des années la présence
d'une tumeur car une tumeur quand elle
grossit lentement elle va forcer le
cerveau à modifier son fonctionnement
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle la plasticité
c'est la capacité du cerveau à s'adapter
à se réorganiser dans notre cas il faut
imaginer que une zone du cerveau qui
habituellement n'est pas utilisé va
prendre le relais de la zone du cerveau
qui est malade sa c'est une bonne
nouvelle la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
ça complique la chirurgie il n'y a aucun
moyen de savoir avant d'opérer
comment le cerveau s'est réorganisée on
avait beaucoup d'espoirs avec les
nouvelles techniques d'imagerie médicale
comme l'irm fonctionnelle ou la tracto
graphie ça fait de belles images ça et
de la science et la recherche mais on
sait que ça n'est pas suffisamment
fiable pour être utilisée sur un patient
donné pour une chirurgie alors en fait
la meilleure façon de faire c'est de
réveiller le patient est de faire
travailler pendant qu'on l'opère mais ça
la chirurgie éveillé ce n'est pas une
nouveauté en 1937 wilder penfield un
neurochirurgien américain avait décrit
la méthode qui utilise et un petit
courant électrique pour stimuler
directement au cerveau si depuis 1937 la
chirurgie et d'anesthésié ont fait
beaucoup de progrès on utilise toujours
le même petit courant électrique pour
comprendre à quoi sert la partie du
cerveau qu'on est en train de stimuler
alors je vous rassure tout de suite
c'est pas dans nos habitudes de torturer
nos passions non si on peut faire tout
ça c'est parce qu'il n'y a pas de
douleur
pas de ressenti non plus quand on touche
le cerveau vers l'autre l'autre
caractéristique remarquable du cerveau
sait qu'il est le seul organe à ne pas
avoir de récepteurs à la douleur en fait
seule la peau du cuir chevelu et des
ménages les enveloppes du cerveau qui
sont situées juste sous le crâne
ressentent la douleur
on peut donc parfaitement ouvrir le
crâne sous anesthésie locale
on fait d'ailleurs très régulièrement
pour des petits gestes comme évacuer
certains hématome ou faire ce qu'on
appelle une biopsie un prélèvement à
l'éguille pour aller faire le diagnostic
d'une tumeur mais comme le dit yes la
chirurgie à crâne ouvert et pas
douloureuse mais se faire ouvrir le
crâne n'est pas forcément agréable et
puis quand on si la boîte crânienne
c'est bruyant ça vibre et ça peut être
perçu comme un traumatisme
la technique de chirurgie éveillé
consiste habituellement à endormir le
patient sous anesthésie générale pour
ouvrir la boîte crânienne et à le
réveiller pour travailler avec à tour
comme ailleurs nous avons quelques
déconvenues avec cette technique des
réveil agité confus des troubles
respiratoires
je me rappelle de ce patient qui a fait
un spasme des bronches à l'induction
d'anésthésie également de cette patiente
réveil agité qu'il a fallu maîtriser
pour éviter qu'elles ne tombent de la
table d'opération
alors ces réactions sont courantes et
banale avec l'anesthésiste général mais
pour la chirurgie éveillé il nous faut
absolument un patient à 100% de ses
capacités à 100% de ses moyens et ce dès
le réveil
alors le risque de mauvais réveil est
une raison pour lesquelles la chirurgie
éveillé bien que botul coupante ne soit
pas pratiquer systématiquement et c'est
la raison pour laquelle à tour nous
avons cherché et une technique
alternative
aujourd'hui tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que la même façon d'opérer des
bastions qui ont un type très
particulier de tumeur qui s'appelle les
gliomes c'est de les réveiller
mais vous l'avez compris la chirurgie et
veiller avec anesthésie locale seul ça
ne nous convenait pas et la chirurgie
éveillée après anesthésie générale
parfois ce n'est pas idéal et en 2010 et
qui est arrivé dans notre service
on savait qu'ils pratiquent l hypnose au
bloc opératoire pour des actes de petite
chirurgie c'est comme ça que stéphane de
lutte qui est ici qui est chef de
service de neurochirurgie de tours a eu
l'idée de proposer enfin de demander à
eric tu es le sentais capable d'utiliser
d'hypnose pour cette chirurgie et en
à tour erik a été le premier au monde à
utiliser l'hypnose pour une chirurgie
éveillé d'une tumeur du cerveau
le 22 septembre dernier à 9h30 du matin
mathieu 34 ans a fait une première crise
d'épilepsie
une fois la crise passée il est allé aux
urgences
le jour même il a eu une irm du cerveau
et c'est irm a montré une lésion
on lui a parlé de christ de masse et aux
gentils je lui ai donné un traitement
anti épileptique et un rendez-vous de
consultation avec moi
quatre jours plus tard mathieu était
dans mon bureau de consultation
ce n'était pas une consultation facile
il était accompagné de son épouse et de
leur dernière petite fille de deux mois
la grande à 4 ans elle est à l'école ils
vont entendre pour la première fois le
mot tu meurs le mot cancer c'est aussi
mon boulot d'annoncer ce genre de
diagnostic et ce n'est pas la partie la
plus agréable
une fois l'émotion du diagnostic passé
il faut aborder la question du
traitement
il faut parler de chirurgie est éveillé
et là ils font dire suffisamment pour
que mathieu comprennent pourquoi une
chirurgie éveillé comme j'aurais besoin
de sa participation active pendant la
chirurgie j'ai encore plus que pour les
autres types de chirurgies besoin qu'il
accepte je veux qu'il soit convaincu
qu'il a tout à gagner en acceptant je
fais des dessins on regarde l'irm tous
les deux pour comprendre la tumeur elle
est un fils 30 allée dans le cerveau ce
qui veut dire que quand je vais l'opérer
je vais pas retirer une boule du cerveau
je vais enlever une partie de son
cerveau malade
c'est pour ça que j'ai besoin qu'il soit
réveillé disposons tous ses moyens
parce que pendant l'intervention nous
allons tester
direct le langage la motricité la
tension et d'autres fonctions encore
donc pendant cette consultation
on aborde des questions techniques
chirurgicales et des questions plus
générales qui concerne la maladie
on va parler de maladies chroniques et
là mathieu commencent à comprendre qu'il
va falloir qu'il fasse le deuil de la
vie d'avant la vie où on ne pensait pas
à la maladie ont fait pas le deuil en
une heure ni même en un mois mais il
faut pas laisser passer le temps trop de
temps car la perspective de la chirurgie
et stressante et on ne peut vraiment
reprendre sa vie en main une fois la
chirurgie derrière soi alors à mois plus
tard mathieu revient il n'a pas encore
accepté
l'hypnose pour sa chirurgie il vient
pour comprendre il a rendez vous avec
l'orthophoniste qui également dans la
salle ce soir qui le prépare aux tests
qu'il va passer pendant l'intervention
puis je le vois en consultation
c'est notre première rencontre je lui
fais une consultation d'anesthésiques
classique puis je l'interrogent sur ses
passe-temps sa couleur préférée ces
lieux de détente
ces dernières vacances et puis ses
meilleurs souvenirs
ensuite je l'hypnotise mathieu regarda
point que j'ai dessiné sur la de ses
poignets
ses yeux se ferment et je remarque des
mouvements rapides des globes oculaires
derrière les paupières fermées
mathieu est en transe son esprit est
parti dans un lieu de détente
peu importe ce lieu il est guidé par son
inconscient cette première personne
expérience hypnotique va permettre à
mathieu de choisir si la chirurgie se
fera sous hypnose ou non la confiance
s'installe progressivement entre mathieu
et notre équipe de praticiens
finalement mathieu accepte l'hypnose
pour sa chirurgie le 15 novembre
de bon matin m'a tuer conduit au bloc
opératoire salle 12 de neurochirurgie au
son de ma voix la voix qui
l'accompagnent mathieu entrent
progressivement en transe hypnotique
on le prépare on met en place une
perfusion une sonde urinaire
puis la têtière à pointe ensuite il y
est complète anesthésie locale du cuir
chevelu toujours au son de la voix qui
l'accompagnent mathieu joue avec sa
couleur préférée elle est entré dans le
corps par sa partie inférieure
puis file le long de la colonne
vertébrale pour envahir toute la tête
qui devient alors beaucoup plus légère
que le reste du corps
j'invite ensuite mathieu a monté sur une
bicyclette une bicyclette bizarre avec
une roue carrée une roue triangulaire
ils pédalent il ils pédalent
pendant que tout le corps pibre la boîte
crânienne ouverte
j'invite mathieu à revenir ici et
maintenant à sortir de sa transe
hypnotique
il est calme détendu et peuvent faire
les tests de façon optimale il s et
l'orthophoniste peuvent maintenant
établie
la cartographie de son cerveau et les
tests vont s'enchaîner pendant toute la
durée de l'intervention en surface
pendant que je vais la cartographie mais
aussi tout pendant que j'enlève la
tumeur c'est comme un petit marathon une
heure trente à deux heures sans pause
pendant lesquelles on est tous
pleinement conscient mathieu aussi
concentré et focalisé jusqu'au bout
c'est fatigant mais c'est tellement
important pour la réussite de la
chirurgie et pour la vie d'après de
mathieu à ce jour nous avons opéré sous
hypnose 57 passion comme mathieu qui
était atteint d'une tumeur du cerveau et
comment fonctionne l'hypnose moi je ne
sais pas et personne ne pourra vous dire
exactement précisément comment
fonctionne du close mais ça marche on
constate que au cours du processus
hypnotique le patient sort du réel il
est dissocié le corps est ici l'esprit
est ailleurs et au cours de la transe
hypnotique le patient modifie son
orientation à la réalité il se focalise
sur son vécu intérieur et puis met entre
parenthèses les éléments du monde
extérieur qui ne sont pas pertinents on
dit également que lorsqu'on met un
patient sous hypnose on inhibe le
cerveau gauche
le cerveau du monde du réel pour
favoriser le cerveau droit le cerveau du
monde de l'imaginaire mais ceci reste
théorique est actuellement des
patientera des chercheurs travaillent
sur le fonctionnement du cerveau
lorsqu'il est en état d'hypnose mais est
ce que ça fonctionne toujours
toujours non la plupart du temps oui car
nous sommes plus ou moins sensibles aux
suggestions de l'hypnotiseur nous sommes
plus ou moins réceptifs à l'hypnose au
cours d'un travail que nous avons
récemment publié dans une revue
scientifique
nous avons pu montrer que six de nos
patients n'ont pas répondu à l'hypnose
nous avons dormi avec de l'anesthésié
générale puis réveillé sans aucune
conséquence particulière mais le faible
taux d'échec
parmi nos passions ce qui représente 10
% dans notre série contre 25 % dans la
population générale peut s'expliquer par
une augmentation de la sensibilité à
l'hypnose en lien avec des événements
particuliers
en effet nos patients sont motivés ils
sont même très motivés ils sont actifs
et acteur dans le soin parce qu'ils
comprennent que nous avons absolument
besoin d'eux pour mener à bien cette
schoren alors la maladie a fait
irruption dans leur vie mais eux
en réponse il s'approprie la technique
du soin donc utilisé l'hypnose pour la
chirurgie des tumeurs du cerveau c'est
possible et ça fonctionne en prenant le
temps en expliquant à nos patients
pourquoi et comment le traitement se
déroule en créant de la confiance
accepter cette aventure devient presque
une évidence pour nos patients on sait
bien que ça peut être une source de
stress
mais c'est aussi une marque de
responsabilité et c'est tout l'art du
médecin d'aujourd'hui
de réussir à mettre le patient au centre
de sa prise en charge
sans faire peser sur lui le poids trop
lourd de la responsabilité médicale
guider nos passions les encourager les
accompagnent en leur montrant qu'on a
confiance en leur capacité à vivre cette
expérience
c'est comme ça que nos patients ces
hommes ces femmes qui viennent dans
notre service pour se faire opérer du
cerveau pour combattre une tumeur
parfois cancéreuses comprennent qu'ils
sont capables de faire quelque chose
d'extraordinaire merci
[Applaudissements]